Rhonda Sanders is writing the blueprint
I think you could argue to save the
world at this point he had a whole bunch
of experts and doctors as I mentioned on
the panel was thrown to everybody live
doing follow-up questions without
looking at notes it was really just a
great uh example I wish you guys could
have seen the behind the scenes portion
of it to really see how on the ball this
guy is one of the experts that he had up
there was ER Dr Joseph Freeman and he
was talking about how he spent most of
his portion talking about how there are
serious adverse effects with these
vaccines at much much higher rates than
other uh vaccines in the past take a
listen scientists Advisory Board votes
against it
CDC goes ah let's not listen to these
guys just recommends it for all age
groups
the safe and effective terminology
that's been used has been based on a
it's just you know it's uncertainty this
is based on it's it's a lie myself along
with uh six other scientists or
international team
we uh
basically went back to the original
clinical trials looked at serious
adverse looking at serious Adverse
Events they're defined by both Pfizer
and moderna and the sign by them
we're looking at that which went in to
reanalyze it take a magnifying glass
look closer because they originally
reported that there was no harm there
was no serious harm from these vaccines
and so we basically were using a list
that was a who endorsed list of Adverse
Events that they thought were
potentially caught going to be caused by
the vaccine before
we ever even authorized it to our
surprise
in the Pfizer trial the first first
vaccine to go through it was a 37
increase in the number of serious
Adverse Events that was never reported
not by the FDA not by fives it turns out
when with both Pfizer and moderna we had
a one in 800 risk of serious Adverse
Events of these are from that list so
now to understand what a one in 800
means consider that our other vaccines
have about a one in a million one in a
million maybe two in a Million this is
not the same sort of safe safe and
effective doesn't change it's not even a
scientific wording safe it's not safe
enough it's it's more of a campaign like
a campaign slogan or not even it's a
advertisement and that one in 800 number
that's for short-term risks that's okay
so the guy you heard speaking at the end
talk about the short-term risk that's
Brett Weinstein who's been on the show
many times I I we've sort of lost touch
over the last couple years but I
reconnected with them I'd love to get
him back on he's going to be on this he
doesn't even live in the state of
Florida uh either to Dr Freeman and
either does Dr badacharya Who we're
going to talk about in just a sec but
they're all going to be part of this
panel which is absolutely spectacular
the key part of what he said there was
not only I get you guys will understand
the sort of dismissals the CDC just
ignoring a lot of the science but the
numbers this one in 800 so meaning that
in when they were testing the Pfizer and
moderna vaccines the MRNA vaccines they
found out that serious vaccine injury
and further uh we didn't play all of it
but he talked about what Syria serious
means I mean it's real stuff it's not
just like my my fingers tingled for a
day it's like real stuff related to your
heart your brain etc etc your nervous
system one in 800 people we're getting
that sort of reaction now you may go
okay well 1800 that doesn't sound like
that much but as he said in normal
vaccines the vaccines that we've all
been taking forever the polio vaccine I
think he mentioned specifically it's one
in a million do you see the difference
between 1 and 800 and one in a million
and fauci's out there every day saying
it's safe and effective which as Dr
Freeman points out safe and effective is
not even a medical term